[Music]
well hello and good morning the uk's
first ever red extreme heat warning has
come into force with temperatures
possibly topping 40 degrees celsius
today or tomorrow that's gonna break the
record for the country's hottest ever
day now people have been urged to stay
indoors at the hottest time of the day
that's between eleven and three as
forecasters one of ferocious
temperatures a national emergency has
been declared with major disruption
expected as schools close hospitals
cancel appointments and people are told
to work from home if they can
well this is the scene across west
london right now as you can see the sun
has risen people are beginning that
monday morning time the temperature is
going to steadily creep up during the
day until it becomes dangerous a level 4
heat health emergency has been declared
meaning that even those who think they
are fit and healthy are still in danger
from the extreme heat
now an amber warning already covers much
of england all of wales and southern
scotland a red warning for extreme heat
is now also in force
now for any area starting south of
london and reaching as far as north as
greater manchester and york some trains
have been cancelled as temperatures saw
with network rails saying in serious
cases railway tracks could buckle in the
heat and speed restrictions are going to
have to be in place now the department
for education is not telling schools to
close but some schools will allow
children to leave early or to wear pe
kip so that they feel more comfortable
and the government is advising people
who can to work from home where possible
our first report this morning comes from
ashland harinac
we've had the warnings and now it's here
today this familiar sight will feel
unfamiliar
over the next few hours extreme heat
will smolder towns and cities between
london and york
many of those winding down after the
weekend are today staying home i'm
choosing to stay at home because i don't
want to get public transport because
it's great going to work
aircon's on but then you're still going
to get home the office has been closed
to prevent people from traveling in in
light of the likely travel disruption so
i'm forced to work from home
i've worked abroad in hot countries as
part of my job so 40 degrees 45 degrees
when i've been working abroad you just
get on with it
but those in classrooms have little
choice
in some of the schools it means closing
some of the rooms in some of the schools
it might mean closing early today it
means all of us making sure that
children have enough water have
protection against the sun are wearing
hats are wearing loose clothing we can't
expect much learning to go on in this
sort of heat is the the frank reality
taking it easy is precisely what the nhs
wants us to do hospitals will be pushed
over the next 48 hours some 111 control
rooms have drafted in extra staff and
urged to only call in an emergency even
then expect a long wait
today of all days is not the day to go
outside network rail have said that
people should only travel if it's
absolutely necessary and for vulnerable
people to not travel at all
by night the risks for them continue
people will dehydrate and the
strain on people's breathing is much
higher again people who are breathing
difficulties are much better set up and
so the overnight heat will give people a
little respite people get very little
sleep in many cases
this is what the water networks will
want to avoid bottles being handed out
to those finding themselves without in
the middle of the most severe heat wave
the country has ever seen
what happens in the skies today may look
appealing but in reality it's extremely
dangerous
ash naharinag sky news
all right let's cross over now to our
correspondent marieke who is in reading
forwards uh
i think you might have your thermometer
there with you and you're at the lido
there just tell us temperature's
probably not super hot now and it looks
pretty shady where you are but it's
going to get very warm today
yes kamali i do have a thermometer with
me and people here are here at tim
slider for their early morning swims
enjoying the shade and uh i have pretty
big one here this which has got the
temperature at a uh a slightly less
stressful 25 degrees for now that will
obviously creep up over the course of
the day
i think you're catching that here look
at the mercury
and it's a place where you can swim
safely a large part of the weather
warnings in the country have been around
avoiding swimming in ponds and
reservoirs the people here have taken
advantage of the great facilities to
have a swim and i'm with ellsworth who
is the duty manager on call on the desk
today um and she can tell us a bit about
how busy it is have you noticed a lot of
people inquiring about swimming yeah we
have been really busy yesterday and
we're building up people are ringing up
all the time to try and get in swim
slots but we're fully fully booked yeah
yeah
tell us a bit about how you've had to
slightly tweak and change some of your
services because of the heat yeah we've
got um our therapy rooms upstairs where
they do all the massages so um we're
giving our therapists a little bit of a
break and the guests a bit of a break in
the middle of the day so they won't have
to have um be up in the hot rooms and
have those hot massages at the middle of
the day so we're here for cutting those
out from 12 15 to 5 45. thank you very
very much for that so it's busy here but
they've had to alter their services
because simply too hot for a sauna at
some points of the day and i think it's
also important to know in those met
office warnings that this isn't just
whether for leisure or enjoyment these
are extreme conditions which will
obviously have an impact on people's
lifestyles and the infrastructure of the
country as well
okay
for now thank you so much for that well
let me just show you a real-time
animation of what the temperatures are
right now across the uk um i believe we
can bring them up for you now there you
go we can see that uh in and around
london it's about 18 degrees you can see
it's a little warmer off to the west
there and also in the northeast 20
degrees up in and around yorkshire as
you can see in the top left of your
screen the hottest place in the uk right
now is actually kenley in surrey which
is reading at 22 degrees celsius we're
going to have of course
those details for you all through the
day but let's just tell you how you can
try and get through this really hot
period and the nights are perhaps most
difficult as we try and get some rest
now here are some tips on how you can
stay as cool as possible first up top
priority for getting through the day is
to keep yourself cool by drinking plenty
of fluids but those fluids do not
include beer or coffee so avoid alcohol
drink plenty of water if you can now it
might seem counterintuitive but staying
indoors and keeping your windows and
curtains drawn will help keep the heat
out now if you're worried about heat
stroke soak your hands and feet in cold
water or use an ice pack on your armpits
and make sure you check in on friends
neighbors elderly relatives and anyone
you know locally including pets to make
sure that they are staying as cool as
possible staying out of the hot sun
and now to get through the nights
prepare ahead
make sure you put your pjs and
pillowcases in the freezer during the
day so they're nice and cool maybe a bit
crispy too before you put them on before
you go to bed dump your duvet and use
cotton sheets instead ideally one per
person as they'll absorb sweat and more
comfortable in the heat and if your home
has several floors you can sleep
downstairs too now use a fan
to help your body regulate its internal
temperature sticking a pan of ice cubes
in front of it can make circulating the
air even cooler little freebie air
conditioner then if you have phone
chargers next to your bed unplug them so
they don't heat up and your devices
heat up you and your devices and the air
around them but if they are getting that
warm should probably get a new
new plug-in now let's get a little bit
more on those unprecedented temperatures
that are forecast for today and tomorrow
i'm pleased to say we're joined now by
the chief meteorologist at the met
office paul davis paul good morning to
you so just how concerned should we be
about the temperatures we're about to
see in the next 48 hours or so
yes thank you yes i'm from the met
office here at the uh the uh operations
center um the heat wave is going to
extend over two days today there's a
good chance we're going to break the uk
record of 38.7
tonight would be very oppressive i mean
it's exceptionally difficult sleeping
conditions and tomorrow is the day where
we are really concerned about there's a
good chance now of hitting 40 or 41
degrees celsius and and with that all
the health rules that come with with
those higher temperatures
now i've just laid out some of the
things that people can do to try and
keep themselves cool but do we need to
be prepared paul that this could be the
way that summers are for the foreseeable
right yes i mean this is entirely
consistent with climate change um you
know to get 40 degrees in the uk we need
that additional boost from human induced
climate
so in that context yes we are expecting
that the sort of levels of extreme heat
that we're going to expect tomorrow
could be a regular occurrence by the end
of the century
and the temperatures we're seeing over
the next couple of days paul i mean we
will have seen the sort of the stats
showing how the temperatures were going
to rise uh a scientist meteorologist
surprised at how quickly we've reached
these 40 degree days
well i've been a meteorologist for about
30 years and i've never seen the charts
that i've seen today
and the speed at which we are seeing
this exceptionally high temperatures
is is is
it's broadly in line what was what we
were saying but to be honest as a
meteorologist to see the brutality of
the heat that we're expecting tomorrow
is quite astounding
and it does worry me a lot and and my
colleagues here in the met office that
this sort of unprecedented heat could be
a regular occurrence by the end of the
century and what will that mean for our
everyday lives paul
well it's yeah it it's we have to adapt
and and be resilient to the changes
coming coming ahead of us and also just
the obvious things about trying to
reduce the impact of climate change you
know just consider some of the aspects
of of reducing your co2 here in the met
office we're moving towards a net zero
policy and it's that approach that in
time hopefully that'll filter through
and reduce the impact we're going to see
tomorrow from climate change
now just talk to us about um the heat i
mean you've described it as uh brutal
heat we've said that it's going to be
ferocious as well these are really um
descriptive words that we're using to
describe what's happening in the next
couple of days
i mean what's that going to be like when
you find yourself
outside and
which times of the day are we best to
avoid being outside if we can
well the peak of the of the heat is due
in the afternoon sort of mid to late
afternoon so that is when the highest
temperatures like to be attained
but i have to say that overnight is also
oppressively hot
and often that's the biggest impact on
health
so in terms of the heat the maximum
temperature during the day in the
afternoon but overnight i also would
recommend that in any way you can try
and cool yourself down because
temperatures in london tonight could be
in excess of 25 degrees
and paul talked to us about you know
we've seen lots of commentary that other
countries deal with this these kind of
temperatures all the time why is it
quite so difficult apart from the fact
that we're not prepared for those kind
of temperatures here in the uk it talks
about the the strength of the sun at the
hottest times of the day and how
dangerous that can be
right talking to my colleagues in spain
portugal and france over the weekend i
mean they've described this heat as
exceptional too
and they've seen and observed
amazing temperatures and the like i say
the brutality of that impact
in terms of the uk
the heat which is have been affecting
spain portugal and france is drifting
towards us
so it's the activity of that plume
and also us generating our own heat
that's causing the particular problems
for tomorrow
and are we likely to see another plume
another wave of uh heat later on in the
summer because of course it's only it's
only july
right i mean we can't rule it out
um when we look to the future in terms
of the next week forecast there is this
there is an easing of the temperatures
in fact the temperatures start to ease
back to what we described as slightly
above normal from about wednesday
onwards but as we move into august you
just can't rule out another plume as
we're going to see the next couple of
days as you run into to august is
because in the continental europe the
heat is likely to be sustainable and
pretty intense as well through the
course of that month and that goes to
the point about if you are traveling to
the mediterranean and you're in
traveling to the continent it's worth
keeping an eye on the forecast because
the temperatures overseas are also
equally very extreme and hot
okay paul davies from the met office to
appreciate your time this morning a busy
period of you but thank you very much
for the information and we i'm sure
you'll join me in saying we hope
everyone keeps safe in the sun all right
let's take a look at the morning's
newspapers now on the metro front page
you can see monday meltdown on monday
temperatures forecast of course we've
said to reach 40 degrees celsius the
front page of the guardian has a
description of the heat as ferocious
here's the front page of the telegraph
heatwave meltdown brings uk to a halt
the sun
the aptly named sun of course is going
to get hotter than the sahara the star
goes for comedies it often does with a
picture of a man enjoying the heat or
perhaps being
exhausted by 40 degree wings very nice
the male claims that conservative
leadership candidate penny mordant met
the leader of the muslim council of
britain despite a long-standing
government policy not to engage with the
group the eye says that the battle to
finish second in the leadership race
appears to be between miss modern and
liz trust the foreign secretary
now the third round of voting to find
the next leader of the conservative
party and our next prime minister takes
place later today the final five
candidates went at each other in a
televised debate last night clashing
over tax character and judgment but they
did agree on one thing there'll be no
place in their cabinet for boris johnson
booting process from here now mps will
vote again today between five and seven
and so graham brady will announce the
results at eight p.m knocking out
another candidate the one who comes last
of course now tomorrow so graham will
announce the results of the fourth round
of voting at 3pm reducing numbers of
runners to three and sky news is going
to host the final leaders debate at
eight o'clock tomorrow then on wednesday
the last round omnb's voting will
produce the final two candidates and on
thursday mps break for their summer
holidays allowing the parties some 200
000 members to select the winner and our
next prime minister
now as i said we've got a special
program coming up here on tuesday sky
news is going to be hosting a television
debate with who wants to be the next
leader of the conservative party and our
next prime minister it's
on tuesday the 19th at 8pm will be
hosted by k burley
still to come on the program i'll be
speaking to the mp dr liam fox who's
backing rishi sunak to become the next
leader of the conservative party
and i'll be joined by ukraine's special
envoy on sanctions alexei market
and we'll hear from the labour party's
shadow leveling up secretary lisa nandi
[Music]
now almost 400 police officers in texas
have been accused of failing to
prioritize the safety of children over
their own a 77-page report into the
shooting at rob elementary in may
identified systemic failures among law
enforcement 21 people were killed at the
school shooting damning police body cam
footage shows the moment one officer was
even scrolling on his phone while
waiting for his superior to open a door
to a classroom our u.s correspondent
martha counter reports
[Applause]
one female
hurry up
[Music]
well as temperatures continue to rise
over the next couple of days government
advice has been to avoid traveling we're
joined now by the chancellor of the
duckie of lancaster that is kit malt
house kit malhouse good morning to you
and thank you very much for being with
us this morning just tell us what is the
government advice right now as we uh
prepare ourselves for this
record-breaking heat wave
so our advice is is broadly for people
for themselves to be sensible drink lots
of water stay in the shade we've got a
hot 48 hours coming but also be very
aware of those vulnerable groups who we
think are most likely to succumb to the
heat so that's the very young small
infants
but particularly the elderly often
living alone who may struggle in the
heat and who i think would probably
appreciate the neighborly thing being
done which is for people to go and knock
on their door and just check that
they're okay and they have access to
water you know many of us are used to
traveling overseas for this kind of heat
we don't see it and i haven't seen it
before in this country so we sort of
broadly know what to do and what we're
asking people to do is is just take it
easy in particular there are going to be
disruptions on the transport network um
and so where the transport operators
have advised people to avoid traveling
unless they have to obviously if you're
using public transport you need to bear
that in in mind but as i say we've got a
hot 48 hours coming and we're asking
people just to be prepared and look out
for the vulnerable
now your colleague dominic robb was on
uh with sophie ridge yesterday i mean
i'm sure you would have seen it i know
you're a avid watcher of the political
sunday morning shows and he said that we
ought to enjoy the sunshine and be
resilient enough um i mean is that
sensible advice there is exactly what he
said we ought to enjoy the sunshine and
actually we ought to be surely enough
though through some of the pressures it
will place do you think we should be
enjoying the sunshine
well look if you're lucky enough not to
be working today and you're going to the
beach obviously i know you'll take lots
of sun cream and water and uh umbrella
and all those kind of things and be
sensible but we need to recognize that
there are some people who will not cope
well in the heat
and what we want is for everybody to
look out for them
lots of people will go about their lives
perfectly normally so for example we
have said that school should stay open
and kids should go to school that are
very often they're safer in schools and
the
kids need to learn obviously and schools
can look after them and hydrate them and
keep them nice and uncool but you know
we just need to be sensible we haven't
seen this kind of heat before in the
country
we need to learn from it and understand
how we operate and adapt our behavior so
we all get through it safely
so with ferocious temperatures you're
still happy for people to go to the
beach and hang out all day in the sun
well some people may wish to um
obviously and it's it'll be cooler at
the coast than it is in the um in the
center of the country particularly in
the midlands and in in london but what
we're saying to people is that they need
to take responsibility to themselves
recognize that this is a really
ferocious heat that we haven't seen in
this country before and adapt their
behavior accordingly now that will
change from person to birth
i mean very elderly people need to
understand that it will be difficult for
them in the heat we all need to
understand that and we want to look out
for them right and particularly small
infants
but i think you know lots of people
understand that we're just trying to
alert people to the fact that this heat
is coming for the next 48 hours and they
need to adapt their behavior accordingly
i mean we've known this forecast has
been in place for a couple of weeks now
what mitigation has been put in place to
make sure that schools can stay open
that hospital appointments can be kept
that the trains keep running what's the
government been doing in the lead up to
this to make sure we can kind of live
our lives as much as possible
well obviously as it became clear that
the the weather was going to produce
this record heat and there's a strong
possibility that we'll hit the all-time
record in the next 48 hours we have been
in close contact with all the public
services to make sure that they are as
ready as they can be so guidance being
issued for schools for example so they
can keep children safe and hydrated
making sure that the health service is
aware that it's coming and that they've
got capacity stood up we particularly
look for example at the 999 service
making sure that the 2400 extra staff
we've got in there that extra capacity
will be able to cope so we're sort of
getting everybody stood up and ready for
the next 48 hours and we just need to to
get through that learn from it and then
wait for the cooler air to arrive on
wednesday so for schools that think that
they won't be able to deal with the
temperatures and the heat that the kids
are facing to think they should close
well we've said that that school should
stay open but that it is a decision for
the local head teacher now there are
some
schools where obviously the building or
for other reasons they may not feel that
they're able to keep the kids nice and
nice and safe and cool and hydrated and
if that is so then obviously it's a
decision for the head teacher but for
the vast majority we believe they should
stay open
okay um you shared a cobra meeting over
the weekend was the prime minister there
uh he wasn't but it is my job to check
over meetings and i briefed him
yesterday morning at about eight o'clock
personally
i mean we've got a red extreme heat
warning do you not think the prime
minister should perhaps have been at
that meeting
no it's literally my job to chair cobra
i in my department i have the civil
contingency secretariat which is
responsible for coordinating the
response across the whole of government
and that's what we've done in the the
two cobra meetings that we've had and as
i say i briefed the prime minister
yesterday morning eight o'clock myself
yeah and he where was he this weekend mr
my house
i don't know his exact whereabouts so
briefed him by i can tell you
he was at czechoslovakian party
all right oh yes sorry i did read that
in the media yes
there he is
so while the country was preparing for
its worst heat wave in a generation the
prime minister was having a party at
checkers
well i have to tell you having chad
cobra on on saturday and then um uh
briefed the prime minister 8am on sunday
i did have some of my family around for
lunch in my constituency on sunday
lunchtime as well i know but you're not
prime minister sir i mean do you think
that the prime minister's just kind of
decided you know he's going to be
leaving the job pretty soon anyway so
there's no point in him paying attention
and being part of these very important
meetings
so as i say that's completely unfair we
communicated on on the saturday or
friday as well and then as i say i
briefed him at eight o'clock on on
sunday morning so he's right across this
i think this is a very unfair
characterization of the media um around
this particular issue right it's my job
to chair cobra it's my job to to
coordinate across government and then to
be accountable to him which is exactly
what i did yesterday morning when i
briefed him i mean you know the point
i'm making this month and it goes to
leadership doesn't it and you would have
thought that when we're facing something
like this the leader of the country
would want to be in the meeting so he
can perhaps lead
our response
well the prime minister has to deal with
lots of things on a daily basis that's
why he like organizing parties at
checkers
why he appoints secretaries of state to
deal with those those issues and as i
say we are now well coordinated we're
stood up we're facing a difficult uh 48
hours possibly and that we
hope and expect that people understand
that it's going to be very hot they'll
look out for the vulnerable and adapt
their behavior so we can all get through
it as safely as possible just a final
thought on this mr martin before we move
on to uh talking about uh the new
leadership race um you said that we are
prepared and we've sort of stood
everyone up
in the event that there is another heat
wave coming do you think that we could
end up drafting in um more assistance
perhaps from the military
well i i can't comment on that at the
moment but obviously we keep all our
options open for for where things may go
you know we want to make sure that we
learn from the next 48 hours about how
we can adapt if it does occur again but
look the weather is unpredictable let's
hope it doesn't
okay let's talk about the leadership
race you will have seen the debates uh
friday and last night i mean what do you
make of the way that the candidates are
going at each other
well to be honest with you i mean i
think it's good to have a vigorous
debate uh within any kind of political
organization you are our democracy and
reaching the right answers for the
future of our country requires this kind
of challenge and battle of ideas um and
so i was losing one of the other
socialists
well you know i mean i i generally uh
adhere to the reagan doctrine of not
speaking ill of another conservative i
suppose some people might see uh being
called a socialist um an insult i'm not
sure that's true in the labour party but
there we are um but you know it's it's i
guess it's a sign of a kind of vigorous
battle of ideas and we need to have that
battle so that we can select the right
leader with the right solutions and then
unite behind that person i mean battle
of ideas is one thing but this is a very
public tearing down of one another and
it's not just about ideas isn't it you
could see that there were points last
night but it got very personal
especially between richie sunak and liz
trust i mean what's that going to do to
the party when it tries to come back
together once this is all over
well look i'm confident uh the
conservative party like any family that
has its internal rows and discussions
sometimes in public um uh that
eventually will come back together again
in the spirit of harmony and love and
unite to win the uh general election you
know it's important that people
recognize that all political parties are
kind of standing coalitions and the
conservative party is the same and a
vigorous exchange of ideas in what is a
challenging time for the country should
be expected when you're talking about
such important issues and the leadership
of a g7 nation if it was just a sort of
polite you know agreement and consensus
across the board there wouldn't be much
point in having the competition at all
so with that in mind then who are you
going to be backing mr malthouse
i haven't declared yet there's still a
long way to go that's why i'm asking you
well i'm going to be listening to the
arguments over the next 24 or 48 hours
and voting accordingly
i mean who do you think did well last
night rishi soon ak
well i think they all did well in their
own way i'm sorry to hedge my bets but
um as i say i thought they all did
well and we'll have to see how the um
the voting goes today you know in my own
mind i'm kind of keeping a
running tally of the various arguments
and as i approach voting this afternoon
i'll be voting
accordingly okay kit well i do
appreciate your time today uh thank you
very much
thanks a lot cheerio
all right let's uh have a look at what
the weather's gonna have in store for
the next couple of days told you we're
going to be having a heat wave 40
degrees expected
tomorrow perhaps it's ferocious heat and
the metal office warning it could be a
danger to life this is the scene
currently over west london as the
capital wakes up to what we are
expecting to be the hottest days for a
generation the advice is if you can work
from home stay indoors during the
hottest part of the day and we'll have
more on this of course throughout the
day here oscar
and welcome back all right let's take a
another look at what the weather is
doing today it's already getting pretty
warm as you can see it's 23 degrees in
cambodn in cornwall this is the shot
over westland it's a beautiful morning
but it is going to be a scorcher so
let's bring in them sky's meteorologist
kirsty mccabe who's joining us now live
good morning to you kirsty eye looks
lovely in your garden i mean what are we
what are we going to be facing today and
how should we do
good morning kamali it's unprecedented
the amount of heat that's heading our
way over the next couple of days we can
expect to be extremely hot and it's not
just located in one part of the uk that
heat is extending northward so for many
of us it's going to be quite a hot
uncomfortable couple of days initially
the air is quite dry i can show you
where the air is coming from it's
actually originating over north africa
and there's been a little cut off
circulation in the upper level winds
that's actually off the west coast of
portugal and that's what's driven the
hot air up towards the uk if you look at
the graphics you can see just off the
coast of portugal this circulation here
that's what's been driving the air
northwards and so we've got southerly
winds at the surface dragging this
really hot dry air all the way from
north africa it's been extremely hot
across spain france portugal and now the
uk is getting a blast of that heat it
will turn increasingly humid as the week
goes on
now across yesterday you can see the
highest temperatures whales having its
hottest day 33 celsius and that was the
uk's hottest day so far but we are going
to northern ireland also had its hottest
day incidentally but we are going to see
much higher temperatures today their
confidence is growing in us breaking the
uk record which is currently 38.7
celsius and growing again that we're
going to break that 40 celsius barrier
we've never had it in the uk and we
could even see 41 that's 106 fahrenheit
tomorrow tuesday's likely to be the peak
of the heat before temperatures dip as
you go through the rest of the week so
39 quite likely today we're looking at
quite high odds in fact over the next
couple of days it's a greater than 95
chance we are going to break that uk
record and on tuesdays a 70 chance will
get over 40 degrees so it's more likely
than not going to happen and then a real
drop in temperatures wednesday thursday
friday although still quite high but a
real drop in temperatures but at that
point the humidity is going to come into
play and i think it's going to feel
quite uncomfortable and it's really
quite uncomfortable at night as well
we're talking about something called
tropical nights where temperatures don't
drop below 20 degrees
let's take a look at the forecast in
more detail
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
already this morning temperatures have
risen and over today and tomorrow we're
at risk of record-breaking heat we've
already seen temperatures haven't
dropped below 20 degrees overnight
across parts of yorkshire parts of the
southeast as well so this morning it is
a very mild start today and soon rising
in that sunshine it's very strong
sunshine as well this time of year so of
course uv levels very high as well we've
got a met office extreme heat warning
across much of the uk so that amber
warning extending northwards even as far
as southern scotland and that red area
that's where we could see the extremely
hot conditions more details through the
morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now with today's temperatures set to
break records let's take a look at some
other notable heat waves in british
history now back in
1976 the uk faced what was at the time
the driest year for more than a century
has drought plagued the country some
brilliant archive picture there you can
see a reservoir looking pretty dry
while the temperatures soared there were
two six day periods when the temperature
reached 32.2 was positively mild the
first time that this had been recorded
in the uk now the peak temperature that
summer was felt in cheltenham when 35.9
degrees was recorded and that was on the
3rd of july
then came 1995 which at the time saw the
hottest august on record since 1659.
temperatures peaked at 35.2 degrees and
is also now recognized as one of the
hottest summers in the uk's history
now of course there are countries where
the temperature regularly hits 40
degrees but if you lived in say dubai or
las vegas the chances are that your home
and workplace is air conditioned whereas
here in the uk we don't build for such
extreme heat but climate change means
we'll have to it'll be a cost and it
will cost us billions of pounds to adapt
our science correspondent thomas small
reports
the temperatures rising with the sun the
next two days are expected to be the
uk's hottest since records began and
we're just not used to it hundreds of
people are likely to die
not just the temperature it's the
definitely the duration and the fact
that you don't get any respite overnight
so you also end up with people becoming
sleep deprived and there's accumula
accumulative dehydration which compounds
the problems
previous heat waves have underlined the
economic impact too
in 2010 5 million staff days were lost
to high temperatures at a cost of 770
million pounds
in the 2003 heat wave road repairs cost
41 million
and in the same year buckling of rail
tracks cost two and a half million in
delays and damage
other countries more used to these
temperatures have invested in more
resilient infrastructure they've
designed their cities to have plenty of
shade and of course they got far more
air conditioning britain just isn't
built to be this hot
only half of england's strategic road
network is surfaced with heat resistant
material
and new houses are still so poorly
designed that they'll overheat in future
well britain just isn't built for the
climate we now have the higher
temperatures we are experiencing
over the next few days and we will find
that our infrastructure our buildings
our roads our rails simply can't cope
with the heats largely and in the future
we're just going to have to retrofit
them which will be expensive but there
is no choice these heat waves are going
to become more intense and more frequent
greenhouse gas emissions of the past
mean summer temperatures that top 40
degrees are already baked into our
future but how often that happens
depends on whether and how quickly we
reach net zero delaying climate action
will simply dial up the heat
thomas more sky news
now conservative mps are going to today
vote for a third time on who they want
to become the next prime minister and of
course leader of the party the five
remaining candidates again went head to
head in a televised debate last night
and they didn't hold back
all right well dr liam fox at the mp for
north summerset and a supporter of rishi
sunak he's with us in syria good morning
to you doctor
love you to have you with you we'll talk
a little bit about heat later because i
think you've got some advice for us um
but first i mean what do you think of
last night's debate how did human rishi
do
i thought he did extremely well i
thought he was head and shoulders above
the other candidates in that debate and
the reason i say that is that of course
we're electing a prime minister this is
not a leader of the opposition this is
someone who will have to be the prime
minister in about seven weeks time
and i thought he had a better grasp of
the detail i thought he was very clear
in what he was saying doing that well
with the conservative party members who
of course he'll have to do well with if
he's going to win why is that well he's
won both ballots so far which i would
say was pretty good
and in a big field a big field and we'll
see amongst the members when the members
get to choose the members don't know who
the two candidates are yet going to be
but i think that what was very
interesting about the debate
and was was one point that rishi sunak
said which was if the conservative party
is not the party of sound money then
what is it about and i think that lies
in a lot of this debate now the one
thing that's very clear is that all the
candidates want to cut tax that's what
conservatives want to do the question is
when is the appropriate time to do that
and i think that when you see that uh
rushi's plan has been endorsed by three
previous conservative chancellors you
have to earn tax cuts the economy has to
be in good shape to do that otherwise
you're simply borrowing more money and
that falls onto the next generation and
i don't think that's either economically
sensible nor
morally uh acceptable and he made the
point force and you make it there but
that doesn't seem to be cutting through
with conservative members because if you
look at the head to heads rishi versus
anyone
he actually uh apart from against tom
tugan that and penny morning by just
he's actually behind on the other two
with when you talk about conservative
members you're actually talking about
the readers of the conservative home
website so that's not the same as
conservative members and it's a fair
representation of the way that the
grassroots feel well when i spoke to my
members at the weekend and i had my
constituency executive that wasn't um
how they felt and they felt that uh
rishi sununu had been performing the
best um of the candidates it's not
surprising he's been the chancellor he's
across all the detail
of government as you would expect a good
chancellor to be and i think that comes
across yeah and we've seen that he's put
out a new
ad for himself just uh before the debate
i think we can have a take a little look
at it now as well uh this is uh laying
out his credentials as a brexiter
he campaigned relentlessly during the
referendum where others argued for
remain
oh others argued for remaining a picture
there of liz trust that's not very nice
politics is that well i think the key
thing about him and brexit is that he
was a young mp i know that he had a lot
of pressure put on him by the david
cameron team
when you're a young mp and the prime
minister phones up and says don't do
this but won't be good for your career
and there's a strong temptation to
follow that line but he didn't he said i
believe in brexit it's something that
drives me politically and i'm going to
campaign for it whatever the cost to me
in terms of um early political career i
think that says a lot about someone and
frankly i think that's what leadership
is all about i mean how do you think he
dealt with some of the personal attacks
that have come at him over the past
couple of days i think last night he did
pause and try and talk about his story
and his family story he told a story
about his father-in-law
i think it was great to hear someone
talking that way about someone who's
come with almost no money built up a
great fortune and that is what our
country's wealth is is based upon and i
think that defense of the creation of
wealth is really important because um we
need to build up more wealth in this
country if we don't build up wealth how
do we fund our public services so i
think it was great to hear that
it was great in a sense in the sort of
academic sense of making the point about
why conservatives believe in wealth
creation but i think it was also a very
human story that a lot of people can
relate to about people come to this
country and they work hard they build up
and they do well and you know that
that's the great thing about our country
uh rishi of course is looking forward to
the final debates to be held on tuesday
he makes it through
i'm pretty sure he'll make it through um
and you know he's he's a consummate
debater he's extremely good at the
dispatch box in the house of commons
he's very calm very fluent very
confident i think that came across and
as i said that he strikes me as every
inch someone who's ready to be the prime
minister in just a few weeks time the
race is on the contestants who would be
the next prime minister are finalizing
their pitches the prize to become the
next leader of the conservative party
and
grab the keys to the most famous door in
the world join me kay burley as they go
head to head live on sky news that's the
battle for number 10 live on tuesday
night at eight on sky news on our app
online and our social media channels
well joining us now is our political
correspondence tamara cohen good morning
to you tomorrow so let's pick up on the
interviews we've had so far let's do dr
fox first just standing fully behind uh
rishi sooner saying that he thought he
did really really well in the debate is
that your opinion as well well look did
the debate change anything last night it
was certainly a bit nastier than we've
seen before the vicious attacks
particularly between rishi sunak and liz
trust on the economy it's a really
really serious divide now and it's hard
really to imagine those two serving in a
future cabinet together penny mordant
tried to kind of rise above the fray a
bit but then she was questioned on what
her own economic policy is with the
accusation that she's failed to set one
out so
we're now getting to the later voting
rounds mps will vote again tonight and
we'll get results at 8 o'clock to see
who's the next person to go out of the
race so we do expect that will probably
be tom tugan hat who got the fewest
votes last time and we'll also see where
suella braverman's backers she got 27
votes liz trust will want all those
votes where they end up going certainly
well okay tomorrow for now thank you so
much for that
now the european union is set to
announce further sanctions against
russia later today including more
restrictions on the import of gold and
further sanctions on individual
oligarchs now it comes after ukraine's
president vladimir alensi sacked the
head of the country's domestic security
services over accusations of treason
well joining us now is the special envoy
on sanctions at ukraine's ministry of
foreign affairs that's alexei mackay of
alexei macca thank you very much for
being with us this morning so we're
going to get those new sanctions coming
we'll talk about that in a moment but
just tell us why is president zielenski
felt the need to sack one of his closest
partners within the government
well president explained it yesterday in
the uh
in the address television address he
does every every evening and he
explained that there are a number of
people in the security services of
ukraine uh who
might work for russia and this is what
counter intelligence does to look for
russian agents
uh and uh to find them uh and to expire
them
i mean is this the only one or do you
expect there to be more of these kind of
people
well this is about to investigate
and in in no way those two people are
accused in
treason no this is not correct but uh
what is important is that we uh get rid
of the soviet past and of the
russian agents uh all over the country
who is now fighting a war against russia
now as i said the eu are going to table
another set of sanctions today um from
what you understand will be in them are
they going far enough
we are happy that sanctions coalition
and the european union
increase the pressure on russia but of
course where
i would never say it is enough
because sanctions is what essentially
helped us in winning this war and weapon
is the most important thing and we
appreciate very much what the uk's
government did for ukraine and all the
partners
of the sanctions coalition did in
providing ukraine with weapon and uh
increasing sanctioned pressure on russia
now one thing that we don't think is
going to be in the sanctions package is
a an oil price cap on a russian oil do
you think that should be something that
is in uh if not this sanctions package
but certainly future ones
of course and uh get rid of the russian
dependence uh of the russian energy is
very important for the whole western uh
coalition
but look
practically every day european union has
been paying uh
over 700
million euro every day to russians
and that's uh made possible to russians
that they continue shooting us with
their cruise missiles just imagine 145
days of war and they shot 3 000 cruise
missiles over ukrainian
territory hitting
civilian infrastructure schools and
kindergartens and hospitals so getting
rid of that dependence stop
paying to russians so russians cannot
produce weapons anymore that killing uh
my country and my compatriots
now alexa over the weekend there was
some reporting from russia that uh the
threat of doomsday if ukraine were to
try and take back crimea and you'll know
that a week or so ago some a million men
were said to be putting under arms to
try and counter attack by the ukrainians
i mean what's the what's been the
response first of all to that kind of
language coming from russia
russia has been lying on an industrial
scale since the beginning of the russian
war against ukraine in 2014
and
if we negotiate with russia if we deal
with russia we must deal from a position
of strength and this is exactly what uk
us in and european union needs to show
to russians do not
bend
do not
try to
agree with the bully
negotiate with russia from a position of
strength uh show strength and show
leadership in support in ukraine this is
the war which will be won by ukraine and
the whole democratic coalition and we
need to win this war
i certainly do okay alexa maki special
envoy and sanctions from ukraine do
appreciate your time this morning thank
you very much for being with us
thank you thank you
all right on to something completely
different and uh the u.s pop star
jennifer lopez has married the actor ben
affleck in vegas three months after
confirming their engagement in 18 years
bloody hell after cancelling their first
wedding
[Music]
definitely one of my favorite songs the
famous pair were proved to be engaged
back in 2002 but called off the wedding
at the time now both went on to have
families with different partners as you
know before rekindling their
relationship last year jlo shared the
news on our website after the couple
tied the knot at a little white wedding
chapel in vegas over the weekend
congratulations to them once we get any
new music or new movies